you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 13
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to discuss with
you a very important topic share with
you a very important term in chess and
that is hole a hole in a chess game or a
hole in a chess position is determined
by observing the pawns and the pawns
alone assessing the pawn structure so
with that said let me make a quick
adjustment to the board here and for
right now at least let's just give some
special attention to the pawns the
little guy is the most important aspect
of a chess game in every chess game
there will likely be holes that white
creates and black creates a hole for
white is a square that can no longer be
controlled by any white pawns similarly
a hole for black is a square that can no
longer be controlled by any black pawns
let me say right off the bat that holes
in a chess position are a weakness they
are a deficiency they are let's just say
a hole in the white position is a window
of opportunity for black to capitalize
on in some way we'll see examples of how
this how this can come about they are a
weakness this topic by the way is one
that is focused on APIs is a positional
aspect to chess a strategic type of
thing with the game assessing
on structures identifying weaknesses
holes within one's position and how
exactly to formulate a plan around this
and take advantage of these gaps in your
opponent's position these are this is
something that a positional strategic
player those two terms positional and
strategic are quite often used
interchangeably this is something that
the positional player strategic player
is exceptional and they identify these
things very well they know how to take
advantage of these holes these
weaknesses within a pawn structure one
of the greatest strategic minds the game
has ever seen arguably the most
strategic player former world champion
many time world champion world champion
from 1975 to 1985 Anatoly Karpov
he was once quoted as saying pawns not
only create the sketch for the whole
painting they are also the soil the
foundation of any position if you're
familiar with golf golf and chess are
similar in that in golf you read the
Greens you know when it comes you're
ready to make a putt you read the Greens
first you assess the Greens let's just
say and from that little assessment that
helps you to do what it helps you know
in what direction you should strike the
ball and at what speed
similarly in chess we assess the palm
structure and from our assessment
determining the weaknesses the gaps
within a structure how the pawns are
positioned the chains that are created
this gives us some instructions of how
we should position or pursue our pieces
where we should position repeat pieces
or where we ought to where we ought to
position our pieces they will provide
very useful information to us assessing
the pawn structure just like assessing
the Greens is helpful too
the player who's ready to put the pawns
are the instruction manual for the rest
of your pieces we're going to have a
look at several examples here but before
I dive into that let's look at a very
specific example let's see a specific
example of a hole and a chess game when
the game begins we of course know that
all white pawns begin on the second ring
they occupy all second ring squares they
do not control the second rank squares
big difference they occupy the second
ring squares but not control they do
control all third rank squares however
they are directly controlling all third
rank squares at least once all of these
squares are under whites controlled by
the pawns additionally all fourth rank
squares have the potential to be
controlled the a pawn for example can
move forward a single step in b4 is all
of a sudden controlled the b-pawn can
also step forward one step and then both
a 4 and C 4 will be under White's
control and if we move continue to move
in this direction from the a file to the
C file sure enough we'll see that all
the other highlighted squares I have up
here are not holes they are under
White's control or have the potential to
be under White's control by the white
pawns we can continue in this manner we
can look at the fifth ranked sixth rank
and continue on up the board at some
point or another all these squares can
be controlled by the white pawns great
there are no gaps when we begin a chess
game no holes when we begin a chess game
let's look at how some of them can be
created as we make pawn rows let's say
that white begins with the move h3 have
any holes been created with that one
move the answer if you'd like to pause
the video and figure it out feel free to
do that I'm going to go right into it no
no holes have been created this one
square was under White's control but
after the pawn moves okay it isn't
controlling g3 but we still have this
pawn around this controlling g3 so no
holes have been created when a rook pawn
moves one square one square has been
weakened when a rook pawn moves two
squares two squares have been weakened
it's no long and no longer has the
potential to go to h3 and control g4
okay rook pawns they move a single step
1 squares weakened two steps two squares
are weakened all of the other pawns it's
double trouble what do I mean by that if
the b-pawn goes one step two squares are
now weakened see three and a three in
fact a three of the two highlighted
squares a three we can already identify
as a whole no white pawns can control
that square from this point on c3 on the
other hand is under wise control so no
no issue there
if the b-pawn goes two squares well now
four squares have been weakened a3 c3 a
for c4 just trying to give you a little
bit of a visual here to help identify
any weaknesses when your opponent makes
a pun move what you can do is look at
the adjacent files look at if the b-pawn
goes two steps look at the a file draw a
line up like so look at the C file you
can visually draw a line up like so
these squares here are the ones that are
weakened are any of themnow holes yes
not c3 and not c4 but sure enough we do
have both a3 and a4 as squares we can
already identify on the white side as
holes something black may very well be
able to take advantage of at some point
we need to be careful of
the weaknesses we create with our pond
movements need to be very delicate when
we move our ponds they which by their
just by their definition they can only
move forward they can never run in
Reverse and repair those weaknesses
there will be positives and negatives
connected with every pond move we make
and I know I'm drawing attention to
these weaknesses that there they create
when you make pond moves and you might
be going in the direction you might be
thinking to yourself already well you
know what okay holes you know their
weaknesses therefore you know I'm just
I'm never going to create any holes in
my position well that's not a good
approach do know that in order to gain
something in a chess game you have to
give something up you will be creating
weaknesses it's okay to do that but you
need to at least be careful about
watching how you can remedy these
weaknesses you are leaving behind okay
we're going to have a look at some
examples of this in action and I believe
we can I think that's everything I
wanted to say before I went into the
first example yeah I think we're ready
to go and have a look at our first of
several examples this one here being our
first with any pond move we're going to
question any holes created no with this
one here we look at the adjacent files
these four have been weakened no holes
though they're watched over the Jeep on
can control this guy and the c-pawn can
control that guy right there so no holes
so far see five no holes 3d six another
pond move so these two squares are they
holes nope okay
d4
let's consider these here one two three
four
none of them are holes we have the beep
on that can watch over the c-file
squares and the f-pawn can watch over
the e-file squares still so no no gaps
no holes for white no holes for black
thus far now you have six nights III a
six another pawn move this is our first
hole b6 this is now a square that can no
longer be controlled by any black pawns
okay but as mentioned you have to give
you know there's a little there's a
positive and negative connected with
these moves so it's serving a useful
role to watch over a knight from one day
maybe jumping here and maybe even it's
it's looking to expand like this
positive and negative connected useful
role watch over b5 but do know it's
something to keep an eye on as white the
b6 square maybe somehow we can take
advantage of that at some point let's
continue Bishop out e5 okay another pawn
move let's consider the squares it
weakens these four are weakened are any
of them now holds f6 is guarded f5 has
the potential to be guarded but we
actually now do have a whole in fact to
d6 and d5 are now considered holes for
black squares that can no longer be
controlled by any black pawns why would
black want to do something like this
week in their position well there's
something gained 'if I've establishes a
strong pawn in the center now combats
White's e4 pawn Chase is a strongly
placed White Knight away is to find a
new home
Knight b3 black now follows up with
Bishop to e6 so this is the point that I
really wanted to draw your attention to
with this exam
and that is when you create holes in
your position you will do well to watch
over those squares with specific pieces
well let's just say the minor pieces do
really well to remedy the weaknesses you
create so right now this D 5 square is a
hole in blacks position and the bishop
is now deploying to a square where it at
least watches over this D 5 square
should at some point white occupy the
square with a knight or some other piece
black always has the option to eliminate
that piece do know that when you create
a weakness in your position if your
opponent is able to position one of
their pieces in in the hole in your
position like a knight right here on
this square if this Knight is able to
stay here he can be extremely disruptive
to the entire black position quite often
when you have your opponent position one
of their pieces in your position you
will do very well to take care of it
almost like right away you really you
don't want to have to work around that
piece it's very it can be very very
disruptive so by positioning the bishop
on e6 in other words should the knight
play here you have the option of at
least capturing it you could play Knight
takes Knight or even Bishop takes Knight
and if the pawn is having to recapture
well this hole is not as much of a an
issue anymore for black if it's if a
hole is being plugged up here with let's
say this this white pawn now on d5 it's
it's now no longer a square that can be
occupied by a white piece something that
would be much more disruptive to black
than a white pawn on the d5 square so my
point here a weakness has been
created on d5 how is this giving us some
instruction this this structure here of
a 5 and D 6 lies the bishop playing the
e 6 of all squares well it's watching
over a weak square on d5 and the bishop
gets my vote
for being of the minor pieces of the
Knights and the bishops the bishop gets
my vote for being the most efficient
defender or the more efficient defender
of the knight and Bishop when it comes
time to secure a weak square the d5
square is weakened the bishop does
really well it sits well it it not only
it not only watches over this square but
does some other things it still has some
other influence in the game it's not
just specific to watching the single
square additionally if it does happen at
some point where let's say the knight is
no longer available to stay on the f6
square let's say somehow this pawn gets
all the way up here and the knight has
to now find a new home well when the
knight moves it's immediately no longer
going to control that weak square d5 the
bishop on the other hand there's if you
could envision that let's say there's
not a pawn on f6 if somehow or another
some way or another
the bishop is let's say attacked it has
the option in some cases where it can
get out of the way from danger and still
fulfill that same useful role of let's
say watching over the d5 square in this
in this in this case here of course you
cannot do that but I'm just trying to
express a difference between Bishop and
a knight when it comes time to secure a
weak square a hole within one's position
the bishop I believe is the more
efficient of the two okay
let's get another move in white castles
Knight goes here and this is
are as I wanted to take this one this
example I wanted to show a couple
instances of holes within one's position
there are three holes for black none for
white and what has black done well
they've at least positioned their pieces
in a way where they are watching over
these weak squares so that in the event
white somehow tries to occupy this this
weak square black is there to at least
get rid of it with a piece the bishop or
the knight
additionally this Knight he is actually
in directly influencing the d5 square
himself it's not just the knight on f6
and the bishop on d5 they're watching
over d5 but the knight on D 7 indirectly
has a say about the d5 square because
one day white might want to do something
like Bishop g5 saying AHA you know what
I'm going to do I'm going to get rid of
one of your defenders of d5 and then
I'll be that much closer to one day
putting a piece in your position and
then maintaining a piece there well
black notice with the night playing here
if the knight is ever captured guess
who's recapturing this guy right here
and he's back to securing the d5 square
this is a very popular position it has a
name but I'm not going to share with you
I don't need to be focused on the name
that's not important what's important
here is what the pieces are doing
identifying the weaknesses knowing what
just this one weakness is can already
give you some insight as to where your
other pieces will stand well those those
of you watching this who are already
familiar with this topic of holes and
such maybe maybe you are familiar with
this type of setup and you weren't
exactly sure of why the pieces are
placed how they are in well maybe this
was a little bit helpful too as a result
looking at the weakness on d5 this gives
our pieces some Direction the bishop on
e6 the knight here too
enforcer knight on f6 who's controlling
that weak square d5
okay let's have a look at another
example another another setup here any
weaknesses no weakness is no any excuse
me any holes for either side
no consider these squares for white no
holes so far these squares for black no
holes night out night out
g3 aha our first hole and it is h3 can
no longer be controlled by any white
pawns okay
g6 there's two holes that are now
created f6 and h6 are no longer can no
longer be controlled by any black pawns
okay both players are preparing to
develop their bishop this has a certain
term I have yet to share in the series
when you move your knight pawn up like
so and then position your bishop in that
pawns place it is said that your Bishop
has been Fein keto to call this a Fein
kettled Bishop Fein cutout Bishop for
black and all that means is you are
positioning your bishop in a way where
it then operates along the
corner-to-corner diagonal the longest
diagonal of the chessboard a Fein ket
owed Bishop okay so already we can
identify some holes that's well and good
but let's take it a step further these
holes for each side they give us a bit
of an idea of what pieces of ours are
now very important to us we have as as
black there are these squares that are
weakened the bishop on g7 he is now an
extremely important piece to hang on to
the four white the bishop on g2 he's
extremely important for white to hang on
to now why is this the case well if he's
not around the bishop on g2 is not
around or the bishop on g7 is not around
White's King might be vulnerable if this
guy is not around blacks King might be
vulnerable if this bishop is not around
it's quite likely in chess that you will
Castle kingside
it's much easier to accomplish you only
need to move out of the way a couple
minor pieces of Knight and Bishop and
you're ready to go King side castling is
quite quite popular and who's going to
be a really good defender of your king
side who is a very important defender of
your Kings side who's a very important
defender of the weaknesses that you have
created on your Kings side the bishop
without this bishop around one day your
opponent may be able to operate on the
h3 square and position a piece there and
it could be quite uncomfortable the
identifying these weaknesses are already
giving us some insight about our other
pieces going with a V and kettle like
this these a king side fiend keto these
bishops are extremely important they
they have a great influence on the
center of the board they stretch along
that main diagonal and they're also now
very important to hang on to without
them around your king can be vulnerable
the the squares near your King can
potentially be exploited okay let's get
a couple more moves in d3 any holes
created these are the squares that are
weakened but no no holes created after
d3 no new holes d6 no new holes with
that move efore any new holes you bet
let's consider looking at the adjacent
files like this after the movie for
Foursquare
have been weakened any holes created yes
three not f4 that's guarded but these
three right here are now holes in
White's position squares that can no
longer be controlled by any white pawns
when you have a hole in your position
it's your opponent will do well to
position one of their pawns in a way
where it controls that square a knight
will have support now when he does jump
into the d4 square that's a nice nice
little setup to shoot for so some holes
have been created with this last move
efore but it does establish a pawn in
the center black connects his Knights he
develops and now we have the move Knight
to e2 and notice a move that we do not
see here by white and that is the move
Knight to f3 there's a reason for this
and this is this the main point I wanted
want to highlight in this one if the
knight is playing to f3 notice that this
gives black an opportunity to eliminate
a piece who is controlling a now very
important Square D for the knight isn't
a pin if the bishop is challenged the
bishop can exchange himself for the
night and now black can now devise a
plan about the the d4 square he can
train his pieces in a way where they
will be maintained on the d4 square and
he can be a very he will be a very
disruptive piece to the white position
I'm just showing you with these two
examples how yes you can create
weaknesses but take care of them
position your pieces in a way your minor
pieces in a way where they provide some
security to these gaps within your
position positioning the knight here is
far better than positioning it on f3
should the bishop play here in this case
now white can always say no
I'm not allowing your bishop to take out
my knight I need him around to secure
this weak spot in my position this hole
in my position on D form okay
let's dive into another example
identifying some holes along the way so
far so good no holes for either side
what about after c4 any holes no there
are not c6 any holes nope Knight f3
Knight f6 take stakes even with a pawn
capture we have to consider have any
holes been created as a result of that
capture in this case no still no holes
for either side Bishop out ecigs okay we
can already identify a hole for black
the d6 square this is quite unlikely
that white we'll be able to take
advantage of this if if somehow you can
manage to get a pawn up here and then
there's support for when or if one of
your pieces get to thats where it's it's
a different story then but that's pretty
far-fetched this isn't a hole that you
could really take advantage of so it's
of course clearing the way for the
Bishop to come out along the diagonal
III okay we have a hole in the white
position in black position a six another
hole has been created B six black is
looking to expand and maybe fee and
Ketel the bishop on the Queen side
Bishop d3 b5 okay there are certainly
things we need to consider now any holes
created with that last move b5 yes
consider now these four squares any of
them weakened yes how many of them all
of them four holes have been created
with that last move a lot of those four
squares this one right here is really
the main one you should be focused on
why exactly well you already have pawn
support
for it so all you're really needing to
do for white is well you already have
the first step you know you have your
opponent has a gap in their position
hole in our position can you position
one of your pawns in a way where
controls that whole white already has
that can we somehow maneuver a piece
here we're going to see about that how
does the game proceed white castle's it
should be seven-night here notice he's
not going to see three he wants to play
to be three and then go in here and he
will be a very disruptive piece when he
is positioned in blacks position on the
c5 square next move we have Bishop d6
and this is an important point already
recognizing this weak square c5 of
course there are these all these squares
are holes in blacks position but this is
really the one that stands out the one
where we have already control of it
we have controlled that c5 square with
one of our ponds the c5 square shook
black be welcome to a dark square Bishop
exchange in the game the bishop played
to d6 but might it have been better for
the bishop to play to e7 these are
things to consider because you know he
has a few options b4 probably not a good
idea I mean he could be kicked from that
Square but it's really coming down to
you know when it's blacks trying to move
where do I go my bishop de7 d6 which
one's better and for what reasons is
east having better than d6 or vice versa
well let's look at the weaknesses let's
look at the weakness in blacks position
c5 it probably a good idea to hang on to
this guy when considering these two may
be best to stay go to e7 avoid this dark
square Bishop exchange that way should a
piece arrive on c5 at least you have the
option of doing what taking it right out
if it becomes bothersome to you okay so
this is just another instance of
recognizing a weakness and how does that
help us make better decisions this is a
very basic decision you know where
should I where should I deploy my Bishop
e7 or d6 or
more more of a question of am I welcome
to a dark square bishop exchange maybe
not so much in this case due to the
weakness on the c5 square okay well as
it went in this game the dark square
bishop swear exchanged white posts up in
the center the knight is exchanged the
queen recaptures and maybe in hindsight
black would have done better to
recapture with the knight as awkward as
that looks why exactly well it's
anticipating something that white is
maybe looking to do I know it's a
backward movable in fact both moves are
backward moves but maybe there's a
reason maybe you you know from this
information if this is news to you maybe
this brings your attention different
ideas seeing how white can be posting up
to c5 maybe it's better to actually
recapture with the knight so you're
watching over c5 in the game it was
Queen takes Knight b3 Castle Knight c5
the Queen is hit the rook occupies an
open file 94 Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Bishop and this is as far as I
want to go this is a way that white can
what we just observed here is a way that
white took advantage of a weakness
within a black position as it stands
right now it's a still a tight game it's
a rough game but white is why does the
preferred side due to the strongly
placed Knight on c5 a knight that cannot
be kicked away by any of the black
pieces it's he's in a whole some some
players may refer to this square as an
outpost square a whole is an outpost
square in an excellent square for a
knight primarily but dunno we're not
limited in these examples I'm showing
you I'm positioning a knight in a hole
in the enemy position but a rook can
very well stand good on a hole as well
especially in this position where you
really can't scare away a rook
so my main point a hole was created on
c5 and this was an example of how light
can take advantage of this how you can
acquire a position where we have a
knight that is really strongly placed
now on the Queen side and he cannot be
chased away he's he's really dictating
play on the Queen side and and placing
certain restrictions on black black has
to be very careful where they position
their pieces to not end up in a fork or
something of that nature okay let's have
a look at another example I just have a
few more examples and we're going to
close with a very famous very famous
game very instructive game all right
identifying the holes so far no holes
for either side let me just double check
yep no holes see for still nothing right
there
Bishop out d5 let's consider boom-boom
one two three four these squares are not
holes but actually these two are and of
these two the one that's really
capturing your tension or should capture
your attention is the one where we
already have pawn support for the e5
square is now a hole in the black
position how can white maybe take
advantage of this let's see let's get
some more moves in III preparing it the
bishop out Bishop d6 and now we have the
offer of a dark square bishop exchange
Bishop takes Bishop and this is an
interesting moment in the game two ways
to recapture how would you recapture in
the game the Queen captured but knowing
the gap you have in your position is
black on e5 maybe you'll give some
consideration next time to taking with
the pawn because what does this do it it
remedies the hole
in your position you're not always going
to have this opportunity it will you
know after the d5 move has been played I
from the definition I said a hole is a
square that can no longer be controlled
by any black pawns well there are rare
exceptions you know rare cases where it
actually can be repaired but it will
require the help of course by white you
know Bishop to d6 next to me III Bishop
d6 light doesn't have to capture here
and allow the pawn to recapture and
black would then have control of e5 so
with you know these these these are some
rare cases but if the bishop is
capturing this well that hole can
actually be repaired in this case in the
game we had Bishop takes Queen
recaptured so this still remains a whole
95-97 the Knights are exchanged where's
he going do you think c3 or d2 he's
actually headed for the weakness in
blacks position d2 Bishop d3 c6 let's
see what this last move any holes
actually yes the d6 square is now a hole
not one that already has pawn support
it's kind of tough to imagine a a white
piece being able to position itself on
d6 but certainly e5 is is not long off
white castles 94 we could take that
night but white doesn't take the 90
plays Knight f3 if you take the night
right now notice after captures how are
we getting to this square can't do it we
can't we can't make use of that e5
square so first we play Knight f3 is
white h6 rook c1 the King goes at the
corner c5 these are of course not best
moves for both sides and by any means c5
the Queen goes back we take the knight
and then play Knight to e5 this is
another case some some may identify this
is like a really good
versus a not-so-good bishop these are
the type of situations that can come
about in a chess game we do have this
very case right now a knight on e5
really strong knight in a hole in blacks
position he cannot be kicked away he has
support by a pawn who's going to chase
him away nobody in one of the earlier
videos from this playlist I showed on
the board I showed the number of squares
each piece the number of possibilities
each piece has from every square on the
board the knight was an interesting
piece to observe the knight on any one
of these 16 squares has a maximum number
of possibilities
eight possibilities from any of these
squares any of these 16 squares you may
want to consider it's just it's just an
idea but just kind of viewing it from a
bit of a Matthew point of view the
relative value of the pieces they they
tend to increase the further up the
board they get so I mean this knight on
e5 you may you know if I were to just
hold the knight in my hand and say how
much is the night worth you'd say three
and we know this from previous video
that's the Knights the the value it's
given by a knight in this position and I
find it very hard to you know I would
not be so quick to buy into the night as
being only worth three in this position
he's a knight that's in blacks position
he cannot be dislodged he's threatening
many things he's placing a certain
restriction on the black Queen she can't
go too far she has to watch over the
bishop the Knights already threatening a
fork here to win material the knight
would being worth 3 from this position
no way
sometimes when you're able to position a
piece like this your opponent already
starts to begin thinking about you know
what I'm going to give up some material
I'm just going to get rid of this guy
yeah I know I'm going to be down a point
material wise but at least I don't have
to worry I don't have to work around
this strongly placed knight on e5 maybe
you would want to view it as when the
night is on this back rank it's kind of
like worth I don't know zero points if
it somehow gets to the second rank maybe
it's worth one third rank to fourth rank
three fifth rank maybe it starts to be
worth I don't know four four and a half
who knows maybe five maybe he's more
valuable than like a rook it might not
be a bad way to view things just giving
you a rough idea I mean you play around
with it however you want you come up
with some system for yourself something
that is going to help benefit your play
some I don't know the exact quote but
some I believe it said that a knight on
the sixth rank and you could you could
go to sleep like if you if you're
somehow able to position a knight on one
of these squares where he has eight
options one of these squares he's just a
Wow
good luck black if a knight is somehow
able to position himself in a way where
he can't be dislodged and he's on these
six rank squares he's going to be a
monster and a half okay
just giving you a little bit of an idea
how you might want to view the position
of certain pieces as they move up the
board here he's in this week's square we
know this now we know that e5 as a whole
the knight is entrenched there right now
can't be kicked away really strong piece
he's probably far more valuable than
just three points okay let's see how
things played out from here rook f6 was
played
in this game but you know some this is
this is an interesting moment black
could do many different things here
black had played this move right here
right and attack this pawn and that
would be a bad move of course one
because it drops the bishop and you
might see that this happens in a chess
game now just thinking hypothetically
suppose this happened in a game suppose
you're playing as black and this is the
position of the knight on e5 and this is
the move that you did okay for many of
you you're thinking yourself you know
okay I'm not going to drop my bishop you
know I'm not going to go after this pawn
I recognize I have to watch over the
bishop fine I believe you I believe that
you're not going to fall for that you
can work around it you're going to do
something different you're going to
let's say I don't know move this bishop
right here and defend against the the
fork great you just sidestepped a little
trick that white had fine you're working
around the knight so far so good let's
move forward a little bit f3 pawn takes
rook takes this rook isn't doing
anything you get your rooks doubled
right that's something you might do
you're just doubling the rooks forming a
battery having two or more pieces
trained along a a file rank or diagonal
black is now forming a battery like this
unfortunately that falls for a tactic as
natural as looking as it is I know I
showed Queen a5 that was like a blatant
blunder but this is natural that looks
is actually still blunder because that
pesky knight that strongly placed Knight
sure enough did what play it in to g6
anyway if rip takes Knight well there
goes your Brooke white is going to be
winning what's my point with this well
one other thing I wanted to highlight on
this topic of holes in a chess game is
that you know if I were to ask the black
player in this position you know suppose
the game did fall like this where the
knight one here takes takes and white
eventually simplified in one as a result
of having this metier
Plus now if I ask the black player you
know what why'd you lose that game if
black comes back to me and says yeah I
fell for a little tactic I fell for a
you know a night fork and I lost the
material is that really a good reason no
what they should be saying is I allowed
my opponents night I created I created
an environment where my opponent was
able to take advantage of a weakness in
that position I have far more respect
for that answer than yeah I just fell
for a blunder no you allowed an
excellent position for your opponent's
piece and they took advantage of the
weaknesses that you created in your
position that's a far better answer than
diagnosing it as now I just blundered my
rope I fell for a little tactic that's
going to happen
these positional features are really
putting white in a position to have
these tactics be very likely and we're
just seeing a very quick example of this
in action
Knight g6 hits and that's an absolute
killer okay let's have a look at another
example one where we can potentially see
a knight end up on the sixth ranked so
far with these pawn moves no weaknesses
okay one weakness
white looks to fianchetto another
weakness for black castle ship out d4
any weaknesses no not yet takes takes
castle h3 this squares weakened but note
no holes have been created with that
last move a six ok one weakness b6 is
now a hole h6 and b6 h3 for white these
are the only holes
right in the in the position Bishop III
night here white steps up to defend here
c3 is now whole with this last move c3
as a whole and also a three
okay h6
Knight d5 Knight takes pawn takes and
what does black do next
what's one move you really don't want to
play as black
well black plays b5 doing what preparing
to fianchetto mmm hang on weakening four
squares and this one right here is the
main one that you should really be
focused on white already has a pawn
they're supporting that square so who's
going to be around to watch over that
square it's got to be the minor pieces
the knight the bishop the light square
bishop is the only one that could do
that and what if he's not here anymore
well sure enough he's kicked f4 you
cannot rely upon C this is one of the
downsides sure you could devote a knight
or a bishop but they have the potential
to be kicked away when you place that
type of restriction on your pieces they
are vulnerable in some sense to the
tactic of deflection right now this is
what White's doing they're deflecting
the night away from defense of c6 so
that when the knight moves what happens
boom Knight on d6 he's an animal he's a
beast he's really really strong and what
is he doing he's hitting the Queen he's
hitting the pawn and making the Queen
move look ridiculous look at that job
it's not a job you want as a black Queen
defending upon not fun she's not free is
she really worth 9 no way this is a
really strong Knight the move b5 should
never have been played why it creates a
tremendous gap on d6 it allows a
fantastic position eventually for a
white knight a knight on the 5th rank we
already saw can be really good 6th
ranked just that much better so
something that would have been better
for black is to actually play this move
not in this position to eventually play
this move it's a little bit
uncomfortable and what I'm going over
right now is a little bit beyond the
scope of this topic but what black
should have done
is play the night move here and then
look to position like this and only then
play the Bishop to d7
the problem with Bishop d7 is that well
actually he's short on squares after f4
there's no safe Square for him to go to
Knight here first then Knight here and
only then I don't know after let's say
something like this the bishop can play
to c8 and by this reorganization of the
black pieces at the very least they are
not creating an exploitable gap in their
position they're not creating a hole in
their position they're not creating a
hole on c6 that white already has
support for okay let's dive into another
example just two more and then a really
nice game to finish up so here we go and
this to the more experienced player this
variation that I'm going through right
now may look very familiar to you
so far we only have one hole a hole for
black on h6z for and actually with this
last move let's consider boom-boom these
four squares any of them holes yes
f3 is defended f4 can be defended
so not those squares but actually these
two highlighted squares are now holes in
the white position yeah d3 d4 and d3 are
no holes so what black can look to
eventually do is first control this
square right here d4 with the pun let's
see how that comes up first d6 it's
preparing maybe this move or this move
striking at the weak point striking at
the hole in White's position d4 castles
Bishop e2 b 5 hits striking at the white
center in a previous video I discussed
you know what to do in a chest opening
referred to some things I pointed out I
said to create and/or challenge a pawn
duo you'll notice that in this example
we have a case where black is allowing
not only upon duel but like a trio and
only a little bit later is striking at
it this is known as a a hyper modern
approach an approach where you know what
you say go ahead you could build up a
strong center but in time I will be
strike in in short time I will be
striking at it and trying to take
advantage of the time that you invested
building up the try and take advantage
of all the Tempe you spent in building
up your center castle Bishop e25 any
weakness with that move yes f3 is and
now an additional hole h6 was a hole and
now we have f6 okay castles night here
on advances Knight up night back don't
be too focused on these knight moves
just yet we have night here on there and
now what to do in this position for
white if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video what move would you play in
this position as white knowing the
things that we've been discussing about
weaknesses holes in the position in what
something you really don't want to allow
you know something you don't want to
have happen to you you don't want to
have your opponent be able to position
one of their pieces in a hole in your
position something you really should
take good care of what would you do in
this position as Y if you'd like to
again pause the video see what you can
come up with okay the best move in this
position is f3 but why why is that the
best move Y is let's say pawn takes pawn
not the best move one more pop quiz
should white capture on f5 with
and how would you recapture if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video see we
would come up with okay let's discuss
this first let's assume that light does
not play the best move f3 we'll see why
this is soon enough why f3 is the best
move but let's see what the best way
would be for black to recapture many
different ways Bishop Knight pawn rook
Wow okay
this certainly has its points capturing
with the pond forming a pawn duo
controlling many squares watching over a
four so that the knight cannot make use
of that but one of the better ones is to
still keep this file half opened taking
like this it's no longer half opened
taking with the knight not developing a
new piece taking with the night so that
he can do what next post up in the hole
in White's position on d4 a square that
already has pawn support and even one
would say in direct support of the
bishop of the Fein kettled bishop this
is going to happen as white if you take
like this this is basically what you are
saying you are saying I'm okay
I will apparently be okay with working
around one day a knight in my position
on d4 he's going to hurt you he is
definitely going to hurt you
somehow or another it's going to happen
that said as white what should you do
you should keep this night out once he
gets to f5 you can't stop them from
getting a d4 so the idea here is to stop
him from getting to f5 and the only way
to really do that is to make sure you
maintain a pawn on e4 make sure you're
able to let's say box the knight out f3
is the best move here so that in the
event of pawn takes you retake with the
pawn and you restrict the knight from
even stepping foot on f5 you can't even
you can't even think about getting to d4
for as long as the pawn is on the e4
square okay
so notice how our understanding here of
the weaknesses the weakness on d4 we
identify that very early on in this game
we're at move 11 right now but we
identified it within just the first four
moves we identified the weakness we know
that we would really not want to work
around a black knight in this position
how can this help influence our
decision-making later on well when f5
strikes we certainly want to be in a
position to make sure we can recapture
with the pun not allow this guy to pivot
here because once he's on f5 he is
getting to the hole in the white
position on d4 one other thing I wanted
to point out some some players out there
maybe I don't know let's say in armored
with certain visual things in a chess
game I'm not sure well III don't have
reasons why this is the case certain
there might be certain setups one does
because it's aesthetic to the player but
this does not translate this does not in
any way imply that it's good chess play
what I'm talking about is if you do
something like this as white if you move
three pawns out and then you go four
pawns out this is actually an opening
but there's no that when you're doing
these moves you are investing time
investing temping you're not you're not
making developing moves you don't need
to move these four pawns out to get just
two bishops out you're investing some
temping and you are creating many
weaknesses if you are moving these four
pawns you could have a closer look at it
I'll just identify it right away these
four squares are now wholes in whites
position so not only by doing these you
know quite possibly aesthetically
pleasing setups where you know what I'm
just going to I'm going to push four
pawns in the center maybe even five or
six because I really like how that looks
well yeah not only are you wasting time
but you're creating gaps you're creating
weak
is in your position so these are things
to really shy away from if for some
reason you know that describes you maybe
if you're if you're really trying to
prove as a chess player steer clear of
these things that may be aesthetically
pleasing to you because know that there
are deficiencies here there are
weaknesses in the white position as a
result of these four pawn advances or I
don't know maybe you're doing five or
six or being crazy stuff like that you
know recognize the time that's wasted
the tempe you are wasting with that and
also the week the weaknesses you are
creating with such a setup okay one more
example and then a game a very famous a
very instructive game so here we go
alright so this example where are the
holes let's see so far no holes for
either side chop chop and c5 okay this
is something that is very popular I
can't tell you how many times I have had
an opponent do this to me like this
exact this these exact moves like I'm
playing is why I play e4 they play e5 we
get a night out yes we're both attack
they defend great d4 chop chop they chop
again I recapture and then they place
five after just these five moves let me
mention that black has already committed
to serious errors a let's back up here
their first error was capturing a d4
what is that doing it's wasting time
that's not a developing move the fact
that's helping me develop my queen I'm
recapturing and my queen is really
strong in this square this is not a case
of oh you brought your queen out too
early and I'm going to attack her like
crazy no sure on this next move black is
moving forward but that's not a
developing move in fact that's a
weakening move and let me go one step
further this a move like c5
tells an experienced player a great deal
about the blacks blacks strength their
playing strength it the move c5 let me
back up the move Knight takes Knight is
a time error okay that admit that
capture on d4 accentuates White's
development makes it makes it more
prominent the move c5 tremendous
weakness weaknesses have been created
with that move let's consider after this
advance these four squares any of them
holes not this square not this square
but the other two you bet d6 and d5 are
not holes it's just how it is
they can no longer be defended by any
black pawns and black will be punished
because of this this is a very
amateurish thing to do the move c5 the
amateur player the beginner like player
doesn't move like this because they
think AHA I'm attacking the Queen and if
they don't see it I may get to Queen but
what's really going on here is you know
what the Queen that these weaknesses
right here will be pounced on by white
they're going to take great advantage of
it and the weakness that you just
created here as early as move five you
know team black the weakness that you
just created here will have you on your
heels for the rest of the game and you
are bound to lose material in short
order it's just how it's going to go
this is these are irreparable weaknesses
these gaps you've you've created on d5
and deform how the game can follow is
Queen check the Queen's are exchanged
and we direct our pieces where they can
one day position on d5 it's an excellent
post for a piece d6 guess where he's
going he's pointing at not only a weak
Square but guess who's on a weak square
this pawn we can identify this as a
backward pawn
he struck out once and guess what here's
a nice move queenside castle king is
safe rook is hitting here he sits twice
how do you defend it you can't you're
already going to drop material we're
just ten moves in and you're already
busted this is a losing position for
black I know it's just a pawn but we
know you're down material we have these
little tricks up our sleeve these little
effective strategies we're going to
trade down so that we're getting King
for King versus King where well King and
pawn versus King we know how to push
through and promote main point here
black created weaknesses very early on
they could be punished very swiftly as a
result of not only capturing the night
like this in advancing White's
development but this c5 move look at the
weaknesses it creates you need to take
that into account the gaps you leave
behind with your pawn advances this is
not a good move very amateurish move the
c5 advance from this position that's a
close to this video which is quite
lengthy already I'm looking at at the
corner man I'm looking at the recording
as a close let's have a look at a game
very instructive game between playing on
the white end Issac boleslav ski and
Georgie Lisitsa n-- okay we have the
game kicking off with e4 c5 no holes so
far no holes I'll point them out looking
at the Panos aha
okay h6 is weakened h6 as a whole Bishop
e3 f3 okay we have another hole III is a
hole it says it has its points it's
stopping
it's securing the bishop on the e3
square so the knight doesn't kick it
away
castles clean up getting some developing
moves in Knight takes Bishop takes Queen
out gang over 'if I've okay so some
holes are created with this how many
exactly well let's consider of these
four how many are holes not this one
let's get rid of that but the other
three are now actually all holes these
three highlighted can no longer be
controlled by any black pawns so of
these of these three which one should
really be standing out well the one that
you already have
on support for so really the d5 square
is a big one to focus in on so the
bishop retreats it's out of the way
Bishop e6 a2 is has some pressure so a3
rook there and now we have the start of
a maneuver that gives up some material
will soon will soon see this white's
idea here with this game is to invest
some material in fact what this next
move will see the idea is to give up
some material in exchange for
establishing a really strong knight in
the black position on the d5 square
starts out with the move c4 this pawn is
hit twice and it's only defended once so
black can win material and does he goes
for it Bishop takes pawn Knight c3 first
attacking the Queen only after she moves
is the bishop captured and now if the
knight plays here the knight gets rid of
it but first Bishop g5 so white had
already identified the weakness as soon
as e5 was played and he already started
to think about a way to take advantage
of that weak square on d5 well the night
is now pinned to the rook he's taken out
and what do we have with Knight d5 a
really strong piece a case of a really
strong knight and a really really sad
Bishop he cannot be kicked away from the
d5 square it's a hole he has support and
he is having a tremendous influence in
the position attacking the Queen
currently Queen h4 Queen e2 Queen f1
just describing it very quickly the idea
is to actually do a little bit of a pawn
storm where you're throwing your your
pawns at your opponent's king and trying
to create pawn exchanges so that the
rooks can attack this is a good idea
when the Kings are on opposite sides of
the board to attack one another's King
Queen f1 you want to play
three without the Queen playing to h3
that would stop the H pond from
advancing so queen f1 only now g3 the
Queen cannot play here to stop the pond
from advancing she would just get
captured she moves away h4 hits
here comes g4 here comes capture the H
files now half opened White is in the
driver's seat look at this Knight he is
at any moment ready to land here with
check and who knows maybe he attacks
something else along the way queen g6 g5
this rook is hanging or is it now I was
actually indirectly defended black would
run into a fork if he captures the rook
h6 rook takes well the bishop can take
right no can't do that again why because
of the strongly placed knight on d5 the
knight that's in the hole in blacks
position 97 would hit and there goes
your queen in yet another way really
strong piece well worth the material
invested light is down upon but or
excuse me not right now he's not down
upon but the investment to establish a
position in this week square on d5 is
well worth that white gave up upon in
order to establish this strong piece to
establish this knight in the hole in
blacks position and he's really
incredible to say that he's only worth 3
he is worth so much more
so Queen takes pawn rook here and it at
this point black already resigned
there's not much to do the G file is
completely open the H file is completely
open the white King's perfectly safe
strong knight silly Bishop dumb rook
where's the Queen go if she goes here
Queen h1 and guess what's happening next
at the very least rook g1 and you could
you could already see what's going to
happen to the Queen she's dead and
there's no way to save it you go here to
interfere with the pin against this well
don't forget about 97 and if the Queen
runs away well that's check and that's
checkmate everything is centered around
this really strongly placed piece in a
hole in blacks position
there's a lot of stuff covered in this
video it's going on for some time now if
you're still with me
hats off to you you have a lot of
patience and I hope you got a real lot
out of this video watch it again if you
have to there's a lot of stuff covered
here going into this one I did not know
how deep I wanted to take certain things
there's a lot more to learn in this one
beyond just identifying again these
weaknesses these these holes in the
position they there's so much more that
you can derive from just this little
piece of information regarding holes in
a chess game and I really do hope that
you got a lot from this one and will
continue to build on this as we go
deeper and deeper into this playlist of
course so I'd like to close with how I
normally do I hope you got something out
of this and we will see what is in store
for video 14 so that's all for now take
care bye